how does it work when like you guys flew
out to Coachella and I'm saying to
myself where where did the money come
from to fly out private to Coachella
when you're a college student I know it
is insane the opportunities I've been
offered and I and just and that's what
people are like how are you doing this
with school and stuff and I'm like it is
so hard to say no when you know these
brands are offering you these insane
things and I get I'm so grateful to
bring all my friends with me and it's
such a cool experience when I see you
flying out to Coachella I assume you're
skipping class or you're going to class
you know I make I work around it
um one of my classes is online and then
other ones it's either like if it's
something I talk to my professors uh
I've tried to work around like how many
absences I can have for the semester but
it's really been like a work school
balance the sequester do professors say
to you listen Alex you're in college I'm
not letting you go together you want to
go to Coachella that's what you're
asking me I mean there's some things
like that I'm not going to be like hey
can you excuse me to go party with my
friend it's like that's you know I'm
gonna take that one but do you like look
at your professors and say you know what
the do they really know I mean I'm
making I'm making millions of dollars
doing this uh thing I mean what am I
going to learn from them I do learn a
lot from them and I have that's why I've
stayed in school and that's a big thing
for me like a lot of people blow up on
Tick Tock and everyone's like well are
you gonna drop out you're going to
finish college you're going to graduate
I am
I loved school and that is so important
to me and a lot of My Success is due to
the stuff I've learned in classes
foreign